welcome back to new rock stars i'm
jessica clements and while boss was busy
falling in love and getting married
lucky he asked me to help break down the
she-hulk series for you this first
episode is so fun and funny and i didn't
know cousins could be so close i have a
ton of cousins but we hate each other
every time we're together we just fight
let's just break down this first episode
shot by shot take a look at all the mcu
easter eggs and details we missed like
vos i promise to keep this business
unprofessional and i won't bark for
she-hulk
let's get into it the marvel studios
title card has now been updated with a
shot of our lady thor from thor love and
thunder replacing what was last seen as
rocket and then they put back on the m
after thor love and thunder by jordan
wearing dragon riding chung chi from
chung chi in the ten rings we open to a
close-up of jennifer walters giving what
at first feels like her audition tape
for she-hulk but she's actually
practicing her closing argument in her
office we have a little clip right here
what is the responsibility of those with
power
do they merely have
an obligation to refrain from the misuse
of that power
or do they have a duty to protect those
without it okay so this opening
perfectly reflects what we'll see
between lawyer jennifer walters just
wanting to be an anonymous lawyer and
she hulk icon superhero public figure
extraordinaire who at times in the
comics has been known to use her name
and presence unjustifiably i mean who
wouldn't you're a hulk as she practices
the camera pans out we slowly get a full
view of jen's very 30 lawyer-like office
she's a busy woman and she works hard
for the money i work hard for the money
the loyal type female-driven show is
already presenting itself and i stand
for it we see some books barron's
business law courtroom 101 her
encyclopedias badass women by rachel
walsh and bill o'neil i suspect that's a
picture with her uncle seeing as the
stylized credits we see a courtroom
illustration of her family at dinner and
that man resembles the bald headed
glasses wearing fellow we have a bobble
head of ruth bader ginsburg and michelle
obama a little alley mcbeal the
graduating barrington wisdom class owl
along with another little owl below owls
and lawyers have similar connections
they are intelligent-wise efficient
they're nocturnal plus they're just
birds of prey so they're recognized as
the animals represent a lot of law
schools and departments a ton of ucla
swag along with her two degrees from
ucla we're introduced to our two
colleagues the cheery supportive best
friend nicki ramos played by ginger
gonzaga the paralegal who's basically a
lawyer trainee they provide support to
the lawyers they can interview clients
and witnesses and prepare documents for
court they're still very important folks
and underwhelmingly unsupportive dennis
bukowski played by drew matthews dennis
in the comics was the assistant district
attorney alongside jennifer walters and
they both hated each other he was
obnoxious and super annoying i mean just
look at him behind dennis we get a nice
framed photo of the griffith observatory
in los angeles if you forgot this takes
place in cali let me remind you behind
nicki we get the traditional brass
justice weighing scales which is
completely for gen doing law with no
connection to moon knight can't you can
you hear me i'll be your vessel we see
jennifer walters deputy district
attorney on her front door our girl is a
prosecutor with her own office the
deputy district attorneys commonly work
under the district attorney this is also
when nikki mentions jen was hand-picked
to go up against glkh and what we know
from the trailers up until this point is
one glkh stands for goodman lieber
kurtzberg and holloway which is an
homage to martin goodman the founder of
atlas comics that later became marvel
lieber for stan lee's real last name and
kurtzberg for jack kirby's formal last
name and holloway who is for holden
holloway the attorney at glkh that hires
she-hulk to be the face of the firm's
new superhero law division and two they
are prosecuting glkh that means this is
probably a test by holding to see jen
aka she-hulk really at work during the
comics holloway offered the job to an
intoxicated she-hulk in a bar but he
always tested her limits and expected a
lot from her he could be testing her
right now with titania we see a second
pair of clothes suit jacket and bottoms
to cover jen in case she hulks out
additionally a lot of lawyers keep extra
clothes at their office for all-nighters
but i'm sure jennifer has also learned
her lesson from ripping out of her
clothes this is when jen breaks the
fourth wall it's so satisfying not only
have we seen similar scenes like this in
fleabag i have to i have to i have to
that's my fleabag tattoo saved by the
bell even deadpool this gag is comedy
stage media gold separating fact from
fiction it shows that they don't take
themselves too seriously but also can
give us the audience much more
information my years in theater and
improv have led to this moment if i were
she-hulk or even just a lawyer i'd need
some help coping with the stress of it
all and that's normal a lot of people
could use a little help and that's why
there's better help this video sponsored
by better betterhelp if you think you
might be feeling depressed stressed
anxious or overwhelmed betterhelp is
there to help betterhelp offers licensed
therapists who are trained to listen and
help you betterhelp allows you to
message your therapist in a private
online environment at your convenience
betterhope's network has over 20 000
therapists with broad range of expertise
and specialties giving you access to
help that may not be available in your
area just fill out a questionnaire to
help access your specific needs and
you'll be matched with the therapist in
under 48 hours once you're matched you
can schedule secure video and phone
sessions and exchange unlimited messages
everything you share is completely
confidential and if you ever want to
request a new therapist you can at any
time with no additional charge over 3
million people have taken charge of
their mental health with an experienced
better health therapist if you're
interested in improving your mental
health with better health you can get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description that's b e t t e r h e l p
dot com slash new rock stars for 10 off
your first month we transitioned to
bruce and jen's trip driving through the
woods of california it's playing money
on it by together pangaea a band based
out of santa clara california this
episode oozes california 30 something
year old regardless but the added music
is sort of an indie cali vibe so a mini
bonus we find out bruce has been able to
stay in human form because he created
the device called the inhibitor so keep
in mind it hasn't fully helped him heal
we saw him wearing in shanxi and head
writer jessica gao has confirmed that
this now takes place a little after
shanxi we've seen variations of the
inhibitor before and captain marvel the
cree created a photon inhibitor to
control captain marvel's cosmic powers
and x-men the inhibitor collar was in
days of future's past also in deadpool 2
they used the colors to neutralize the
mutant's powers inhibitor simply means
to slow down or prevent a particular
chemical reaction which i believe
ultimately smart hulk is doing to stay
in bruce form eating hot cheetos with
chopsticks is i kid you not the only way
i'll eat them and for the same exact
reason you don't want to get it on your
fingers also let us not forget who
started this trend moon knight when jen
said you're not the only genius in the
family bruce retorts though there's
there's also a chat at the end we get to
the montage of courtroom illustrations
this one says mom dad aunt uncle and
cousin i assume that chet is the cousin
the uncle is wearing glasses mom and dad
are on the right so that leaves one of
these last women as the aunt this could
be cassandra pike from the comics jen's
aunt on her dad's side she's a biologist
and won a nobel prize for biology she's
also pretty evil in the comics she tries
to kill her brother in niece she-hulk
using her son in this case ched after
giving him injections to become a giant
monster so the quotes around aunt could
stem from an unhappy relationship
between the two like us jen has some
theories truly all her theories are
whether or not steve rogers had sex and
win which don't worry we'll get into
because the mid-credit scene is a doozy
we get a glimpse of the sakara ship we
later learned specifically it's a
sikarian class a courier craft a postman
if you will or someone serving a
subpoena to bruce possibly this could be
from the grand master the ship and thor
ragnarok the commodore looked exactly
like this either way this ties to thor
ragnarok and i bet they're looking for
their top tier fighter after stealing
the prize [ __ ] from the grand master or
we could be getting into world war hulk
and scar son of hulk after the
illuminati sent hulk into space away
from earth for being too reckless he
landed on sakaar creating a home there
even finding love and a wife the ship he
arrived on explodes killing his pregnant
wife and a lot of people in the city he
made he goes to earth storms up a bunch
of chaos and kills a ton of folks it's
revealed the child didn't actually die
he emerged from a cocoon scar is super
sick super hardcore but i just don't
think that major scene would be played
out in she-hulk but you let me know what
you guys think in the comments we're in
the comics she was shot and we got a
blood transfusion from bruce that
changed jennifer to she-hulk this is
technically another type of blood
transfusion just not as thorough this is
great to note how strong bruce's blood
is which yes we already knew but the
fact that like most viruses die on a
hint of mass oxygen this clearly does
not and it can impair someone by a
teaspoon forth be it the leader whose
brain started acting weird an incredible
hulk or blonsky who with an already
petri dish of other concoctions turned
into abomination though hulk's blood
isn't the be-all end-all superhero drug
the amount of gamma radiation in it is
still lethal so where it worked for
she-hulk seeing as they share the rare
genetic factor it makes sense it would
work on her shoot it maybe works on her
mom but don't bet on any normal civilian
every time we get the sad shot of jen
now she-hulk outline reflection on the
green crush door and her silhouette as
she backs up and runs away into the
forest like a crazed werewolf this scene
is so funny to me the transformation
scenes in most movies are she awakens at
ideal sports bar a very funny name for a
sports bar and also a real sports bar in
atlanta georgia and cricket's rocks on
gas and mcu the roxanne corporation has
been seen in loki during the storm and
the first iron man they fought near the
roxon corporation building an ancient
carter it's revealed that they created
the atomic bomb based on the formula by
howard stark in she-hulk comics she-hulk
prosecutes them when danger man
accidentally falls into a bat of hard
atomic water on the job roxan is a huge
powerful petroleum industrial company
and they usually do a lot of shady stuff
in the comics jen sneaks past the
bouncer in the hallway there's a sign
that reads ladies night when you
actually use the qr code it takes you to
the marvel website that offers you the
first issue of she-hulk free to read
along with some special promotion
additionally in the bathroom there's
some lovely graffiti we have the miss
marvel lightning bolt which is funny
because if this takes place during 2024
miss marvel takes place sometime in 2025
who pre-drew this and in california no
less possibly someone anticipating the
arrival of miss marvel someone like kang
who we will see in ant-man and was
quantomania that'll probably take place
in california kang just stopped by this
dive bar and on his way to northern
california and straight up graffiti the
crap out of it we see rest in peace
biggie for big smalls if you don't know
don't stop get it get it used in tons of
songs but i think its origins are by
luke i want to rock i know this because
2 life crew remixed it don't listen to
either if you're under 18. a little
spider not just spiderman if you
sprinkle when you tinkle be a sweetie
wipe the cd and then the infamous sorta
anarchy symbol infamous 420 with a peace
sign and a zero not a single thanos is
right in sight it's ladies night and
what's ladies night without a bunch of
ladies helping ladies in the bathroom i
can't tell you how many ladies nights
i've been to where it becomes a drunk
girls night out in the bathroom those
people become my best friends
immediately just like these helpful
bunch played by monica garcia bradley
tiffany denise hobbs tony bryce and
ariana marie hagan i love these atlantan
queens and i'm so happy they're
showcasing supportive women just women
helping women we need that she hold
donned a led zeppelin t-shirt and i
think those are swim trunks we can
assume these are tony's clothes seeing
as tony loved rock and roll the black
sabbath t-shirt and the first iron man
he's in a small truck with soldiers
listening to ac dc's back in black he
listens to ac dc a lot plus they're on
the coast of mexico at a beach house you
need trunks my dude these little
glimpses and reminders will never be
forgotten tear me apart in the show as
jen walks out to this beautiful rich
beachfront estate we see some little
tony hulk treasures like the iron legion
armordroid helmet from age of ultron i
suspect this is the helmet ultron is
first scene wearing it matches the
degree of damage in the movie they also
remove their mask when the machine laser
beam their eyes so i'm thinking it's
just the junk pieces from that moment
behind her peep the subtle helmet there
that's hult's helmet he wore in the ring
during thor ragnarok it's insane he
still has it it's also not the only
piece of swag brought back from sakaar i
suspect but we'll get back into that in
just a moment we also see a sand
hourglass some boats driftwood art maybe
for the sandy beach aesthetic it's
definitely their relaxed spot tony signs
bunker is insane this is where bruce
spent the 18 months fixing himself look
at all the stark equipment the similar
gear used to monitor hawkeye and age of
ultron when he was getting new tissue
and the first iron man the gear behind
him when he's asking pep to take out his
heart as vas said in the trailer
breakdown we see the x-ray of jen's
brain we have different vials of jen's
green blood lying around while she was
out he was able to get blood x-rays
literally everything we also see the
schematics of the inhibitor behind him
this slow zoom when jen mentioned she's
changed realizing she's a hulk is so fun
and for the visual story and telling
enhances the emotion of the scene and i
love when movies do it like we're
creating the same chaotic realization
for both the character and the audience
it's also so dramatic unnecessarily
dramatic
we find out that jen and bruce share a
rare combination of genetic factors so
like i said earlier what would have been
a lethal dose for most was not for jen
jen's blood is slightly different the
way it synthesizes gamma radiation was
able to fully heal bruce's arm when
channeling a distressed emotion jen
offers pixar's inside out the scene
spoiler when bing bong dies he dies okay
it's dramatic who's your friend that
likes to play i can't listen to it we
also see the saw stark industry and
jen's right what psycho has this torture
bunker
[Music]
when bruce says casually how he changes
back to bruce form is by falling out of
a plane like in the first avengers or he
gets knocked out by a robot as tony as
hulkbuster or natasha would tell him a
lullaby both in age of ultron hey big
guy sun's getting real though he
mentions his high amounts of car him
being stuck as hulk for two years during
the ragnarok all these callbacks are
worth going back and watching because i
just love them dialectical behavior
therapy is a psychotherapy that started
with treating personality disorder and
interpersonal conflict in this case
definitely being a hulk and a reminder
hulk participated in yoga to help him an
incredible whole he mentions jen reverts
back to jen form when she sleeps which
is also what she did in the comics in
very funny ways like when she wakes up
from having men over and has to revert
back before they notice if stress and
high heart rate changes you into hulk
form it would make sense when you're
unconscious you revert back to your
normal self the song playing is fast
motion by my girl sweet tea she's active
in this video sprinting playing soccer
football cheerleading it's all about the
hype and hard work just like what bruce
got jen about to be doing effortlessly i
might add get ready for these lady pump
up jams let's go through the physical
skills he teaches jen i love their
competitive nature but also that boulder
that hulk just tossed is gonna be a
meteor to some poor ship or planet
its infamous hulk jump or leap if you
will we've seen it done many times in
age of ultron when he saves natasha or
when he saves tony mid-fall in the first
avengers movie what i love about this
scene is where smart hulk is taking this
seriously jen is like this is easy and
makes fun of him the complete time
balance and yoga which jen is now a
full-fledged pro at this whole ground
pound which to me jim looks much better
at just saying bruce says jen when you
have powers like this it's like putting
a target on your back in the backs of
all the people you care about which is
so true i know she's upset at this point
but in the comics this is how her best
friend died in 1980 ron of she-hulk jill
stevens offered to help all the time
when it came to her best friend jennifer
walters at a neighbor's barbecue jen got
a call to come pick up some stuff from
the da's office jill offered to pick it
up instead once she left they realized
it was a trap and unfortunately they cut
jen's brake lines in the car and in a
horrible collision jill died jill does
resemble nikki ramos in she-hulk series
but i don't think it's her and i don't
want it to be her but for story purposes
it might be good if she dies smart hulk
is making the world's largest martini
and like steve rogers it takes too much
to get these two drunk and cool you'll
always be buzzed but never drunk i drink
to get drunk you guys also this sounds
so expensive is it even worth it from a
later shot there's about 30 empty
bottles yes some are wine bottles but
regardless if each bottle is 20 bucks
give or take that's around 600 wasted
okay i'm done being irritated but this
logically just doesn't make sense and i
want them to stop it's a waste of money
whatever behind hulk is a whole pinata
perhaps a souvenir from the celebration
of hulk on sakaar they had the helmet
earlier we saw the ship we're keeping
zakar on the back burner always later we
see a different angle from the bar where
we see another cutout of hulk smug hulk
am i right we see the initials bb for
bruce banner in ts for tony stark carved
into the bar bruce gets into the time he
spent with tony creating the bar which
was during the blip and it's sad to
reminisce but i think we're getting to a
spot in the mcu when thinking of tony
shouldn't make you sad he lost him but
happy at the memories they got to make
with him a good time during a hard time
which she-hulk is adjusting to as well
we get the whole thunderclap we last saw
him using this an incredible hulk this
move extinguished fire turned boulders
to rubble smacks the crap out of your
foes the thunderclap shockwave destroyed
and it's fun seeing both hulk and
she-hulk using it though she-hulk's
feels like a thunder applause thank you
i'll be here all night jen breaks the
fourth wall again this time as she-hulk
but this time hulk hears her and maybe
she'll start to recognize you can't just
do that anywhere like in fleabag people
notice in fleabag season 2 the priest
interacts with her interacting with the
camera he acknowledges it a lot so
perhaps later down the line we can see
someone close to her recognizing what
she's doing just added fun jen is now
carving her name into the rebuilt bar
and now called bruce's bar the two have
settled down and enjoy their hot cheetos
with chopsticks i think it's cute that
hulk's are party size again his
metabolism is hefty he's always eating
small amounts the tiny tacos in end game
the party size bag of chips just get
this man a damn buffet am i allowed to
curse in this
uh we pan out of the shot from the
courtroom illustrator to see glkh giving
their closing statements to judge price
who we see in the recent trailers and
recognizes being transformed into an
asgardian type elf so if that still
judge price is beyond me right now but
the defendant is played by brandon
hirsch we also get our first look at
holden holloway played by steve coulter
titania is seen busting through the
courtroom played by jamila jamil titiny
in the comics has hated she-hulk from
basically the jump because she wins time
and time again one-on-one with she-hulk
but i suspect with the other trailer
footage where we see titania everywhere
she was hired to break through the
courtroom so they could see jennifer
walters change to she-hulk like i said
earlier i think it was all orchestrated
by holden holloway who was a shady
[ __ ] man should i should i try saying
shady man keep the f out you can blur it
we'll bleep it jen punches titania into
next week and she slips her heels back
on ready to give her closing statement
to a damn classic by eve who's that girl
it's such a bop basically the song
announcing the queen bee has just
arrived and you're all gonna wonder who
she is in the credits we see a
courtroom-like illustration montage one
of which is a board-like presentation by
jen to hulk at bruce's bar piecing
together whether or not captain america
is a virgin links to peggy carter a
faceless woman and then what we can
expect as a uso showgirl and so let's
get into this jen fake drunk gets smart
hulk to spill some beans on steve rogers
being a virgin they even called back to
the gorgeous steve rogers butt did you
see that ass like that ass did not
deserve to diverge it's revealed he does
indeed get down he lost his virginity to
a girl in 1943 on the uso tour now jen's
presentation may lead you to believe it
was a uso dance girl but i think that
she thinks that the unnamed 1940s girl
was either a dancer or a random woman i
think it's laura haddock aka the
autograph seeker and captain america's
first movie aka star-lord's mom laura
haddock played meredith quill as well
the two roles are not related at all i
don't think meredith quill was born in
1961 this girl was a adult by
40s but come on the scene's two on the
nose they definitely hooked up i mean i
would that's everything i spotted in the
first episode of she-hulk follow me on
instagram and twitter at lulu underscore
clemens follow new rockstar subscribe to
new rockstars for more breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye dudes
[Music]
can i eat this cheese now